join now by Ben Shapiro editor-in-chief
at daily wire com who wrote about this
today and Ari Fleischer former White
House press secretary and a fox news
contributor gentlemen great to have both
of you with us today Ben you know
obviously that the underlying story here
is is ugly it's it does not look good
and the more we learned about it today
and went through some of these blogs and
and the information that's out there
it's a big fall for Rob Porter there's
no doubt he but he helped write the
State of the Union just a few days ago
and now he's lost his job your thoughts
well no question it's a major fall for
him but it seems like a fall that is
well deserved from the from the
credibility of the allegations and of
course it's got multiple allegations
from multiple different women I have a
police action that was filed against a
temporary restraining order the real
question here is what did John Kelly
know and even if he only knew some of
the allegation why would he allow Rob
Porter to get so close to the president
that really is the question to me
because it's it's clear to me that from
what kelly has said what the
administration has said he didn't for
example have access to the photo of the
ex-wife who was hit in the face and once
that came out he changed his story but
when you're in doubt you got to keep the
president safe from the impact of having
someone around him who's going to take a
fall like this and it just seems
irresponsible to me if you know anything
about these stories to allow anyone with
with those allegations floating around
about them to be that close to the
president wounds the president was the
president of all internal position you
know it is it's it's tricky and
obviously the way that Ben presents it
Ari you know is from the national
security perspective which is absolutely
a valid question to ask here you know
from the personal side when you read the
account of his first wife she talks
about the fact that everyone loved Rob
that everybody always told her how lucky
she was that she was married to him that
he was such a great guy this is clearly
somebody who had a pretty good Jekyll
and Hyde routine going yeah and I think
that's what explains why people at the
White House said what they said about
him look this is human nature has
nothing to do with whether you work at
the White House and work in a school or
wherever you are if there's somebody
that you know you admire you like you
say that and it's reflected in what you
think because that's how they behave in
the office they may have a totally
separate way of acting when they go home
and perhaps that's what the case is here
fairness to Rob Porter he's denied this
and and that is important we do have to
have two sides and I think that would
explain that then when people could be
so shocked that he's such a great guy at
the office we don't know what he's like
at home and then you have to be precise
in your language when you say was he
aware of this what exactly is this is it
that there's a picture of him with a
wife who has a black eye or is it there
are allegations of difficulties in a
marriage and we don't know all the facts
yet this is where you just have to let
the investigators really tell you what
do you know what was precisely conveyed
and said yeah let's play a little bit of
the news conference today at the White
House talking about how they handled it
I think it's fair to say that it that
you know we all could have done better
over the last few hours or last few days
in dealing with this situation I the
White House accepting some blame there
well I mean I think that's exactly the
right move and it's one of the rare
times I've seen the White House actually
say listen we may have made a mistake
here you're gonna buy an awful lot of
credibility from the press and from the
public when you say listen we didn't
have all the information as we got all
the information it became clear that we
jumped the gun on this and that
obviously should have been their first
response is we're gathering all the
information these allegations are
obviously very disturbing I think the
reason that John Kelly is in some
trouble here is because he made such a
strong defense of Rob Porter and then
had to go back on it but acknowledging
when you make mistakes yeah a lot of
people in politics see that as a
weakness I think that's actually a
strength when it comes to the PR efforts
for the Trump White House but you know
in terms of the media reaction there has
been a real pile on on General Kelly for
what he said about the daca recipients
earlier this week that if they hadn't
signed up you know maybe they were too
lazy to sign up for the program it feels
like there's there's some Long Knives
out for him it does feel like that it
feels like there there's a feeling that
that John Kelly if he's the guy who's
protecting the president and he's the
guy who's not holding the president back
I think the press wanted Kelly to be the
guy who was sort of holding a leash on
Trump and of course that's not Kelly's
job Kelly's job is to organize the White
House in a better way it feels like
there's some vulnerability for Kelly now
and the press is jumping on it because
they'd like to see the White House
return to something more chaotic as it
was earlier before Kelly sort of took
the reins here